[Music]
crack open this nice jar pickles and I'm
going to pour out almost all of that
liquid but leave a little bit on the
bottom all that pickle juice is gone but
it's being refilled with ponus Reposado
organico paa Patty okay just a touch of
a g y that caption Nick is rized at this
moment I knew I was r
going to bring a little bit of treble
put a little Jalapeno in there maybe two
slices maybe three oh okay that's not as
pickly as I thought it would be which is
I think a good thing I'm let you do the
honors all right all
rightow look at that bursting with life
now into our glass garnish with some
deal sprinkle it to he on top that right
there is our pickle Margarita garnish it
for a pick that's illegally in here have
a sweet
wow this is better
it gives you a party in your pent why
does he speak in
like like the way he speaks is like he's
like characters all the time
yeah marination nation that better than
I thought like he talk like bumblebee
that's illegally good yeah everything
everything's a [__] like OverWatch
character like catchphrase everything is
a [__] green light like little you
know sticky or whatever yeah it's all
emotes yeah
that yeah exactly that's illegally good
you gave our very own Joy bayar a foot
massage a highlight highlight in my we
have
a this start
robing that's so wild to just make a TV
host wet yeah
Jesus
Christ just turning somebody on during a
segment hi thanks for coming to Studio
how are you
doing stop dude I'm getting
[Applause]
[Music]
wet what's crazy is they show this clip
and there's still no like real context
why did why did he do this so is he on
the show again and they're showing this
as an old clip to him be right
back know
whatever never a good is it's always a
good day I so happens I got a pedicure
this look at that dude no bro she's been
bro is this the same woman yes she's
been dreaming of this moment for years
years she's like we got to get him back
on the
show what every meeting every writer's
room for for [__] 10 years I was
thinking Matthew come if we had Matthew
mccon back on the show it's been a
minute I think it'd be
great you know where I got this though
this is my dad's
trip oh I am dripping wet right
now says
that
she's a little bit older she doesn't
have a filter anymore I am frothing
right now let me tell you this [__] is
barking
barking let me tell you the dogs aren't
the only thing that's barking
Matthew this [__] is
[Laughter]
puring that's this [__] tearing the
zipper apart
[Laughter]
[__] she starts getting vulgar how are
you do my puss
in you know be gra you put that kind of
pressure on my
[__] with that fat
[__] Matthew I want you to [__]
me oh manew this woman start so great
why would you bend me over this desk and
[__] my little [__]
that is not as pickly as I thought it
was my dad would do this to my my I got
two older brothers every time we'd have
a date come over we notice they started
to come over to the house early wait
what what see see we weren't done we
were not done my dad would do this to me
and my brother hold on we're not done to
their dates
you remember where where that was
inspired from is my dad you like they
commenting on the flexibility of the
dogs yeah he's first of all what's up
with that [__] pitcher's grip yeah
seriously Matthew Matthew ow ow ow you
see the way I knuckled that yeah yeah
you got to peel a back
like like a
horse would do this my got to Brothers
every time we'd have a date come up we
noticed they started to come over to the
house earlier and earlier like we're
going to look going out at 8 and they'd
show up at 7:00 why you showing up at
700 when when you walk out of the room
ready to go on the date who's sitting on
the couch get a foot rup your
date and we were
[Laughter]
12 I'm like Dad we just going to the ice
cream store why you rubbing up on her
feet my dad look over and be like it's
going to be a long
walk
damn that's [__]
crazy
girl oh [__] oh
[__] I gotta be honest Matthew I didn't
hear what you just said cuz I just came
I just busted
my Matthew I have to be honest my
clitoris is vibrating I just I'm shaking
I just busted in my bres bro that face
girl
oh wow W you're a great reflexology is
she can't even talk she's
like Matthew I just had a full-blown
orgasm Matthew are you familiar with the
Big
O in there get on my resum yeah all
right not so hard not so
hard I'm just going to let all Let Go
by not so hard Matthew save some for my
[__] I like everyone keeps laughing
like they're trying to get them to wrap
up and Matthew Matthew's locked Ino
Matthew's [__] locked in tweaking
honestly he's tweaking out on that foot
is it possible to be locked in and
tweaking at the same
time my boy is L&T locked and tweaking
dude
appreciate
it dude he gets done rubbing her foot
and he's just
like just IM like thank you so much
M licking his paws like a dog the rest
of
[Laughter]
theck
oh
[__] God damn Matthew I'm gonna be so
honest's gonna need a nap after this I
truly will yeah the boys are giggling oh
[__] this is must we've laugh in a long
time yeah yeah since a week ago this
since we were [__] making that
Nutcracker choke on on a
flute